requiere del trabajo combinado de una gran cantidad de personas,
de distintas áreas:
arquitectos, biólogos, diseñadores, mineros, arreadores de cabras,
todo lo que puedan imaginar.
Decidí denominar mi proyecto:
"Miles de gracias".
Porque terminé agradeciendo a más de mil personas.
Y fue abrumador, pero también maravilloso.
Ya que me permitió focalizarme en cientos de cosas que salen bien, día a día,
en contraste con las tres o cuatro cosas que salen mal.
Y me recordó la increíble interconexión del mundo.
Aprendí muchísimas cosas durante este proyecto, pero me centraré en cinco.
La primera es:
Levanta la vista.
Comencé mi misión de agradecimiento con la barista de mi cafetería local,
Joe Coffee en Nueva York.
Se llama Chung y es una de las personas más optimistas que existen.
Tiene una gran sonrisa y le gusta dar abrazos,
pero incluso para Chung ser barista es complicado,
porque se encuentra con gente en un estado muy peligroso.
(Risas)
Ya lo entendieron: antes de tomar café.
Chung ha tenido que tolerar a gente que le grita hasta hacerla llorar,
por ejemplo, una niña de nueve años
a quien no le gustó el dibujo que Chung le hizo con la crema en su chocolate.
Así que le agradecí a Chung y ella me agradeció por agradecerle.
Lo dejé ahí, no quise continuar en un bucle infinito de agradecimientos.
(Risas)
Pero Chung me contó que lo más difícil
es cuando la gente ni siquiera la trata como un ser humano.
La tratan como si fuera una máquina expendedora.
Le entregan su tarjeta de crédito
sin siquiera levantar la vista de su teléfono.
Y mientras ella me contaba esto, me di cuenta de que yo he hecho lo mismo.
He sido esa mala persona.
Y en ese momento juré que, cuando hable con las personas,
voy a tomarme dos segundos
para levantar la vista y hacer contacto visual.
Porque esto te recuerda que te estás comunicando con un ser humano,
que tiene familia, sueños y recuerdos vergonzosos de secundaria.
Y ese breve instante de conexión
es muy importante para la felicidad y la humanidad de ambos.
La segunda lección fue:
Huele las rosas, la tierra y el fertilizante.
Después de Chung, le agradecí a este hombre.
Él es Ed Kaufmann.
Es quien escoge qué café servir en mi cafetería local.
Viaja por todo el mundo, desde Sudamérica hasta África,
buscando los mejores granos de café.
Así que le agradecí a Ed y, a cambio,
Ed me enseñó cómo degustar el café como un profesional.
Y es todo un ritual.
Tomas la cuchara, la sumerges en el café y luego sorbes haciendo ruido,
haciendo mucho ruido.
Es así porque tienes que dispersar el café por toda tu boca.
Tienes papilas gustativas en ambas mejillas, en el paladar...
El café tiene que llegar a todas.
Cuando Ed hacía esto le brillaban los ojos y decía:
"Este café sabe a manzana honeycrisp, con un toque de tierra y jarabe de arce".
Luego yo sorbía y decía:
"Siento gusto a... café".
(Risas)
"Me sabe a café".
Pero gracias a Ed decidí saborear el café unos cinco segundos,
todos estamos muy ocupados, pero decidí gastar cinco segundos
y concentrarme en la textura, en la acidez, en la dulzura.
Y comencé a hacer lo mismo con otras comidas.
Y esta idea de saborear se relaciona con el agradecimiento.
Los psicólogos explican cómo la gratitud consiste en tomarse un momento
y aferrarse a él tanto como sea posible;
en ralentizar el tiempo,
para que la vida no se nos pase de un solo trago, como sucede a menudo.
La número tres es:
Encuentra las obras de arte ocultas a tu alrededor.
Una de mis conversaciones favoritas durante este año
fue con el hombre que inventó la tapa de mi taza de café.
Y hasta ese momento,
no les había prestado atención a las tapas de las tazas de café.
Pero disfruté hablar con este inventor, Doug Fleming,
porque era muy entusiasta.
El sudor, el esfuerzo y las lágrimas que puso en el diseño de esta tapa...
Yo jamás lo había considerado.
Él afirma que una mala tapa puede arruinar el café,
puede bloquear el aroma, que es muy importante al momento de beber el café.
Así que él... es muy innovador,
es como el Elon Musk de las tapas de tazas de café.
Él diseñó esta tapa en forma de hexágono invertido
para que puedas acercar la nariz y disfrutar el aroma al máximo.
Me gustó mucho hablar con él, hizo que me diera cuenta de que hay
cientos de obras de arte a nuestro alrededor que damos por sentado.
Como el botón de encendido de mi lámpara de escritorio, que tiene una hendidura
donde mi pulgar encaja perfectamente.
Cuando algo está bien diseñado,
su proceso de creación es, por lo general, invisible.
Pero prestarle atención
puede incentivar nuestra sensación de asombro y enriquecer nuestra vida.
Número cuatro:
Fingirlo hasta creértelo.
Al final del proyecto, estaba en un frenesí de agradecimientos.
Me levantaba y pasaba horas escribiendo emails, enviando notas,
haciendo llamadas telefónicas, visitando personas para agradecerles
por su contribución a mi café.
Y algunos de ellos, honestamente, no lo creían.
Preguntaban cosas como: "¿Qué es esto? ¿Una estafa piramidal?
¿Qué estás vendiendo?"
Pero la mayoría de la gente estaba conmovida.
Recuerdo que llamé a la mujer a cargo del manejo de plagas
del depósito donde se sirve el café...
Perdón, donde se guarda el café.
Y le dije:
"Esto puede sonar extraño
pero quiero darle las gracias por mantener los insectos fuera de mi café".
Y ella contestó: "Sí, suena extraño, pero acaba de alegrarme el día".
Fue lo contrario a una broma telefónica.
Y no sólo la afectó a ella, también me afectó a mí,
ya que suelo levantarme cada mañana con mi humor de siempre, que es malhumor,
pero me obligaba a escribir una nota de agradecimiento
y luego otra, y otra.
Y descubrí que si actúas como si estuvieras agradecido,
eventualmente te sientes agradecido de verdad.
El poder de nuestras acciones para cambiar nuestra mentalidad es extraordinario.
A menudo creemos que el pensamiento influye en el comportamiento,
pero el comportamiento puede también influir en nuestra forma de pensar.
Y, finalmente, la última lección que quiero compartir con Uds.:
Practica seis grados de gratitud.
Cada lugar, cada parada en este viaje de agradecimientos
generaba otras cien personas a quienes agradecer.
Así que viajé hasta Colombia para agradecer a los campesinos
que cultivan los granos de mi café.
Era en este pueblo pequeño,
y llegamos allí a través de caminos llenos de curvas y riscos.
Y en cada curva cerrada el conductor se persignaba.
Y yo le decía: "Gracias".
(Risas)
"Pero ¿puedes hacer eso con las manos en el volante?
Porque estoy aterrado."
Pero llegamos y conocí a los campesinos, los hermanos Guarnizo.
Es una finca pequeña donde hacen un café genial.
Les pagan por encima del precio promedio.
Me mostraron cómo se cultiva el café.
El grano se encuentra dentro de la fruta llamada cereza de café.
Y les agradecí.
Y me contestaron: "No podríamos hacer nuestro trabajo
sin el trabajo de otras cien personas".
La máquina que se usa para extraer los granos de la fruta es de Brasil,
y los camiones que recogen el producto
tienen partes que son construidas en distintos lugares del mundo.
De hecho, EE. UU. exporta acero a Colombia.
Así que viajé a Indiana y les agradecí a los fabricantes de acero.
Entonces me di cuenta
que no solamente se requiere de una aldea para hacer una taza de café,
se requiere del mundo para hacer una taza de café.
Y esta economía global, esta globalización, tiene desventajas.
Pero creo que las ventajas a largo plazo son mayores,
creo que el progreso es real.
Hemos mejorado muchas cosas en los últimos 50 años,
la pobreza mundial ha disminuido.
Creo que deberíamos resistir la tentación de retraernos en nuestros silos.
Y deberíamos rechazar este incremento en el aislamiento y el jingoísmo.
Lo que me conduce a mi última lección, que es mi esperanza
de que podamos usar el agradecimiento para incentivar la acción.
A mucha gente le preocupa que el agradecimiento tiene una desventaja:
estar tan agradecidos puede volvernos complacientes.
Pensaremos: "Oh, todo es espectacular, estoy tan agradecido".
Resulta que ocurre lo opuesto.
Las investigaciones demuestran
que cuanto más agradecidos nos sentimos, mayores son las chances de ayudar a otros.
Cuando estamos en una mala situación,
solemos centrarnos más en nuestras propias necesidades.
Pero el agradecimiento te hace querer reconocer a otros.
Yo experimenté esto personalmente.
Es decir, no soy Madre Teresa.
Todavía soy un egoísta la mayor parte del tiempo,
pero soy mejor de lo que era antes de este proyecto.
Y es porque me hizo cobrar consciencia
del funcionamiento de la cadena de suministro,
me recordó que lo que yo doy por sentado
no está disponible para millones de personas en otras partes del mundo.
Por ejemplo, el agua.
El café es 98,8 % agua.
Así que deduje que debía ir a agradecer a las personas del reservorio de Nueva York,
cientos de ellos, gracias a quienes contamos con agua
y con este milagro de abrir el grifo y obtener agua potable.
Millones de personas en otras partes del mundo no gozan de este beneficio
y deben caminar horas para poder obtener agua potable.
Esto me inspiró a pensar cómo podía ayudar a que la gente tenga mayor acceso.
Investigué y encontré un grupo maravilloso llamado 'Dispensers for Safe Water'.
Y me uní a ellos.
No estoy esperando que el comité del Premio Nobel me visite,
pero son pequeños pasos, es algo.
Y surge todo a partir del agradecimiento.
Y por esto incentivo a otras personas, amigos, familiares
a emprender sus propios caminos de agradecimiento,
porque es una experiencia que transforma tu vida.
No tiene que ser café.
Podría ser otra cosa, como un par de medias,
una bombilla eléctrica.
Y no hace falta que viajen por todo el mundo,
pueden comenzar con un pequeño gesto,
como hacer contacto visual, o enviar una nota
al diseñador del logo que les encanta.
Se trata de una forma de pensar,
ser conscientes de las miles de personas involucradas
en todas las cosas diarias que hacemos;
recordar que una persona en una fábrica creó la tela de las sillas
donde están sentados ahora;
que alguien entró a una mina
para conseguir el cobre para este micrófono,
para que yo pueda dar mis agradecimientos finales,
que es agradecerles a Uds.
Miles de gracias por escuchar mi historia.
(Aplausos)